And so in practice what we ended up with is not this idea of coming up with a good partitioning
for the input domain rather than a notion of test coverage.
What the test coverage is doing is to try to accomplish exact the same thing
that partitioning was accomplishing, but it goes about in a different way.
Test coverage is an automatic way of partitioning the input domain
with some observed features of the source code so let me say what I mean.
So one particular kind of test coverage that we might aim for
that is sort of an easy kind of test coverage is called function coverage,
and function coverage is achieved if we managed to test our system in such a way
that every function in our source code is executed during testing.
We will be dividing our input domain in chunks where any test case in this part
of the input space is going to result, for example, in a call to foo.
So now, there's going to be some different subset of our input domain
and any point in this subset of the input domain when used as a test input
is going to result in a different function in the system under test--let's say bar being called.
We can keep subdividing the input domain for the software under test
until we have split it into parts that results in every function being called.
So now, of course, doing this in theory is easy.
In practice, we start with a set of test of cases,
and we run them all through the software under test.
We see which functions are called,
and then we're going to end up with some sort of  a score.
So, for example, some sort of a tool that is watching our software execute can say--
we called 181/250 functions.
And so what this kind of score is called a test coverage metric.
It means that our test cases so far have covered 181 of the functions
out of the 250 that we implemented.
And so now that we have achieved this goal that we had,
which is assigning a score to a collection of test cases.
The next thing we have to ask is this score any good?
Is that a good test coverage to have executed 181/250 functions?
With this example, it's probably not.
So, we can do is for each of the functions that wasn't covered, we can go and look at it.
And we can try to come up with the test input that causes that function to execute.
There is some function baz here, and we can't seem to devise an input
that causes it to execute, then there are a couple of possibilities.
One possibility is that it can't be called at all. It's dead code.
Another possibility is that we simply don't understand our system
well enough to be able to trigger it.
Either way, there is something possibly suspicious or wrong.